today  a fan jumps onstage during beyonce and  jay z's Atlanta concert on Saturday  night a concert goer got on stage while  the power couple was performing  [Music]  several videos show a man in a white  t-shirt and black gym shorts making his  way past security up a set of stairs  it's unclear if the man was able to make  contact with the Carters but the fan was  seen fighting off backup dancers and  security guards before being taken away  soon after the incident Beyonce's rep  posted a photo of the couple on  Instagram with a reassuring message for  fans quote thank you to all the fans for  your concern they are fine and looking  forward to the show tomorrow this isn't  the first mishap on the on the run to  tour in July the 36 year old singer had  to be rescued from a flying stage that  stopped working thankfully queen bee was  brought down to safety with an emergency  ladder  Hey  [Music]